33 second Disney logo in the 90s makes
me thankful this isn't a Pixar joint as
well one of the best animated movies of
all time opens with something powerful
and dramatic and for so many of the
images and a will constructed opening
we're gonna take all three sins right
off the bat these lazy ass birds are
lazy this is a ritual that needs to be
done for some reason even God shares his
approval of the new lion cub by shining
light down at the appropriate moment
hopefully he'll save Simba's dad when
the time comes - he's as mad as I hit a
with a head there wouldn't any mammal
with a hernia pee and basically the same
amount of pain / anger scar pretty much
had no choice but to be a villain since
his parents named him scar and he was
born with eagle eyes robbed him is this
something that happens enough that we
fossa is only mildly upset that scar
tried to swallow Zazu why would say we
even show up at his lair by himself if
that's the case what am I going to do
with him I don't know but after the
scene I would definitely be on the
lookout for scar to pull some
straight-up Hamlet
in the next couple of days son do I so
they have James Earl Jones and Matt
Sinclair to basically reprise their
roles as king and queen from coming to
America so does that mean Simba is gonna
go to Queens and work at a McDowell's
the symbol one day could pull over for
having a transvestite hooker in his car
everything the light touches is our
kingdom manifest destiny what about that
shadowy place that's beyond all borders
okay first of all if it's a shadowy
place then the light ain't touching it
and Simba shouldn't have to ask second
of all you've just said the light and
sight where your borders but now
suddenly oh yeah we have interior
borders around that scary place I forgot
everything you see exists together in a
delicate balance that's why they're a
gazelle bounding nearby with no fear
whatsoever that I might eat them at any
moment just like the real Africa when we
die our bodies become the grass and the
Antelope eat the grass and so we are all
connected in the great circle of life
I'll be sure to tell the Antelope that
when they're grieving over their loved
ones getting eaten Mufasa Simba Mufasa
allow Simba to be addictive as loyal
servants I never get to go anywhere
you're like six days old dude Jesus when
I'm
what will that make you why does
everyone assume that scar won't die well
before Mufasa does and why does scar
think he'll ever have a shot at the
throne anyway scar seams will be on the
ears where his possible royalty would
even matter that much to it he should
have thought about killing Mufasa long
ago before Simba was even born
Simba walks in on Nala while she's
taking a bath betrothed intended a fee
honest I mean you're gonna do it oh I'll
just press the button for the stimulator
I mean the elevator but you two
turtledoves have no choice having no
choice is like the baseline attribute of
a Disney character Simba is outlining
exactly how he'll bring about the
downfall of the entire kingdom
selfishness and excessive playtime this
whimsical break in the song could have
been genuinely tragic look I know we're
in a cartoon musical where anything can
happen but I'm drawing a line at
synchronized animal pyramid stacking
Zazu surrounds this damn it all right
right our plan to distract Zazu with
song and then trap him under a rhino's
but came off without a hitch how can
lucky are we
hey genius it was my idea it was like
distinctly remember you saying so how
we're gonna ditch the dodo oh and it was
Simba doing the talking until Zazu
interrupted so how did you come up with
it Nala you lying whore the elephant
graveyard is creepy and cool but how do
all the elephants know to come here
right before they die wouldn't some of
them be like dying right here where I am
or are you saying they died but then
other elephants or hyenas or some animal
carries the bones all the way here just
to keep this creepy spot of thing Zazu
zombie corpse shows up just in the nick
of time to start what we here at
cinemasins would now like to call the
flying dead do we order this deer to go
no why cause Derek oh nice joke
considering you spent precious seconds
of a scape time to come up with it
where's a zoo do you even worry about
Zazu anymore after a rhino sat on his
body hungry hyenas have a hot bowl to
put food in that merely makes said food
last off like a rocket no wonder they're
starving this is the longest spine
anyone has ever slid down to escape in
the history of spine slide escapes
I'm actually fine with Mufasa knowing
Simba was in the elephant graveyard but
knowing exactly where he wants to save
him in time so scars plan to get Simba
into the northern border actually worked
but if he successfully killed Simba then
what was his plan to then kill Mufasa
literal big shoes to fill reference you
deliberately disobeyed me you just said
that two minutes ago deliberately
disobeyed me this is a repetitive dad or
a copy-paste screenwriter discuss well
no and one is that like that was a long
scar yeah they were they were very alone
for a good long while but then you
started talking before eating them and
let them run away somehow then they
weren't alone Wow scar found a way to
get nature itself on board with this
musical number oh this is a huge
previously unseen hyena contingent just
sitting around in the dark until now
seems like scar has the power to become
King right here just simply through song
if you can find the right lyrics
something insane what happened and I bet
you could do throne Mufasa and no time
maybe fright and wildebeest would
Stampede down into a Gulch like this
maybe they wouldn't I have my doubts but
my real question is with the route
that's steep how come half of them are
falling and slipping and rolling all the
way down this steep ass goddamn rock
surface tons of clear area to the right
here but Simba also went to the
prometheus school running away from
things
Cinda is for any length of time able to
outrun the hurt simplifies out of
mufasa's mouth here but of course isn't
trampled because it's math Oh
okay well this movie has some balls but
death of Mufasa is something very few
cartoons are willing to do its plot
appropriate it's dramatic so we will
remove five sins
despite that those scar gets a massive
lucky break after being super unlucky
doesn't this whole plan should
definitely work without a hitch but
Mufasa is a bastard and survives all the
way up to the point where scar is forced
to straight-up murder him not only that
everything with the cliff is perfect so
that Simba doesn't see this dad getting
your hopes up wildebeest also where the
hell was this guy when the massive
Stampede was going on did you oversleep
or something did he wake up and look at
his watch and say I'm late for the
Stampede run away never returned
question why doesn't he just kill and/or
eat Simba right now there are no
witnesses and if he's telling him to run
away there's obviously a benefit for
scar to having Simba out of the picture
and he's a wimpy baby lion who you
already tried to have killed earlier
anyway so why send away alive the one
dude that can challenge your claim to
the throne this is so much worse than
monologuing him all right this is even
worse than not killing him why didn't
you kill him six seconds ago why are you
letting this turn into a game for the
hyenas and he wanted dead right there
the fools that fill you last time dog
Cinda has to climb this to avoid the
hyenas but the movie glosses over that
and he's at the top before they even
catch up Simba survives this Simba's mom
just accepts he's dead with no body to
be found
mere hours after everything went down
Zazu conveniently forgets that scar
punched him into a rock a minute ago
when this started getting real it's
almost like he forgets the guy has all
the markings of a true villain that this
is what he wanted all along and he was
probably responsible for it Buzzard
starts swirling around an animal that is
clearly not dead and hasn't begun to
decay for them to be attracted to it yet
Timon and Pumbaa ex machina but my
question is why do they even give us it
means no worries for the rest of your
day
even if it'll get done promise that's
not bad
wait cute song but shaving his claws
down like this is a horrible idea that
only in dangerous him further out here
in the wild you don't you my friends
doesn't stood down
seriously fart jokes are the literal
easiest laziest comedy there is and it
bothers me to see them in otherwise
brilliant films like this also Papa not
in front of the kids
oh so it's completely okay to show and
sound out farts on screen just not call
them by their name gotcha hakuna matata
glosses over the thing that made Timon
an outcast did he murder a family of
four I bet he murdered a family of four
how a bug's life should have ended Simba
definitely wasn't interesting during the
time he grew into an adult so we'll tell
that story and dissolves as he walks
across along Zazu can get his head
between these bone bars but not the rest
of his tiny ass body scar wanted to be
king for some reason own food sure he
had enough more women uh knowing scar
definitely not so what the hell did he
want for being king at least King
Claudius wanted to get a wife out of the
deal I don't see what scars motive is
the only thing he did was make the
hyenas and lions live together and been
prophets it's a small world after all oh
no anything but that annoying DisneyToon
was around even in the time Africa
existed Oh
on a scale of lazy-ass writing burp
jokes are literally one slot above fart
jokes nope wait that up I'm wondering
something did Disney ask Billy Crystal
to do this voice and when he turned it
down they got Nathan Lane to do a Billy
Crystal impression something you think
these flower petals spell out sex when
symbol falls into them I think a lot of
you have dirty mom hey look I think I
see a vagina in those flowers ninja
magic medicine monkey is so ninja I
wonder why any of this movie had to
happen movie about remote African
animals simply jam-packed with
pop-culture references you know for kids
thankfully for the resolution of the
story Nala wanders really far from the
bride lands to hunt and does so on the
huge continent of Africa in the exact
direction where Simba is yeah close one
there also Nala a freaking force of
nature lioness can't catch up to a
freaking warthog by the way Simba should
get his ass kicked in this fight he's
been living the Hakuna Matata life
remember he has I never had to hunt or
do anything badass his entire life she
was all mom wait a minute Pumbaa was
food a minute ago are you telling me if
someone pouches for him he sees
be food lady have you got your lions
cross has any Disney movie love puns
more than this one
I don't think so is what I'm saying
I realize they know each other as kids
and were betrothed even as kids and that
there's still the only two lions way out
here but still this hey I recognize you
now I love you seems rushed as hell well
they're not running away from any danger
but a sudden Hill shows up again I don't
know where that they can fall down
possibly so this g-rated film can now
something that substitutes our sex scene
without alarming the NBA Tim if you
don't do something soon everyone will
starve okay why can't you do something
why can only the heir to the throne we
just now learned was alive do something
now are you satisfied
no post-coital argument he's alive I saw
him two old Rafiki gets Simba's hopes up
again only to show him the idea of his
dad being alive is one of those
metaphorical things I think Simba would
have been happier with one of those
Hogwarts paintings of living dead people
he lives in you the power was inside you
all along cliche cool part of the movie
I suppose but what Simba have gone back
to claim his throne without this
supernatural dad vision I feel like his
character would have been stronger if he
hadn't needed this vision to make the
choice am I alone here he was a good
soldier god yeah maybe so but he was a
kid when you died if you end this
magical clown power before maybe you
could have given him a boost
Simba's going home but you know what
this scene isn't inspiring enough let's
add a shooting star you know what we
need another okay one more and we'll
call it a perfect shot I do
man the vegetation all dies the weather
is terrible everything about this entire
ecosystem is based on the sitting lion
Kings evilness or goodness you guys have
to create a diversion oh really what did
you plan to do of Timon and Pumbaa
didn't make the trip huge distraction
caused in order to remove three percent
of the hyenas in their path seems worth
it Tammi it's not true it's true Simba
tells the truth but somehow doesn't get
the full story one that he would easily
be forgiven for even if it's 100% true
you think there's an adult he'd be like
my stupid little kid roar caused a bunch
of wildebeests to Stampede I think not
then
no I'm not a murderer I mean seriously
Simba makes things way worse by simply
not telling the story and murder
does anyone at the pride actually think
baby Simba could have pulled off a
straight-up murder of Mufasa lightning
strikes nearby and sit on fire during
the climax cliche wait is going on well
it's over now Benson has joined the
battle also the was this asshole waiting
for the battle to turn in the hero's
favour are you talking to me out here in
foreign Hey call me mister Hey
finally taxi driver and in the heat of
the night together at last
run run away scar never return
hey that's exactly what scar told Simba
to do earlier villain does symbols to
justify the good-hearted hero straight
up killing them cliche I'm sorry I want
him to win for sure but Simba has never
been in a fight unless during that
unimportant time where he was walking
across a long at age five years he's
somehow joined a dojo or something we
didn't see he should get his ass kicked
right here rain comes to wash away the
fire just in time for Simba to be king
again you think with this kind of higher
power there would have been a conflict
to begin with Simba does the thing that
killed his dad in the first place and in
no time all the vegetation and life grew
back and began to flourish solely due to
the moral compass of the current king a
saw arranged marriages are always
accurate perfect and you shouldn't fight
them
ah
yes even Kings get scared huh
fear leads to anger anger leads to hate
hate leads to suffering look at the
Stars different flavors I got them I got
the sighs see I got sighs I got blades
look at mush greet the dawning of a new
era in which lion and hyena come
together dogs and cats living together
mass hysteria names furlough go buy them
obi-wan never told you what happened
with father he told me enough
he know I
you can't change the past the book says
we may be through it the best the past
him through with us it's my fault it's
not your fault
look at me son it's not your fault I
know it's not your fault Timbers gone
back to challenges uncle to take his
place as king oh you have sentenced us
to death perhaps they had better do so
and decrease the surplus population